Simplifica la raíz cúbica de "125x" a la sexta "y" cúbica.
Ahora, tomar la raíz cúbica de algo,
es lo mismo que elevar ese algo a la potencia 1/3,
así es que esto es igual a 125 por "x" a la sexta por "y" cúbica elevado a la potencia 1/3,
ahora sí tenemos el producto
de varios términos que se elevan a una potencia,
eso es lo mismo que elevar cada uno de los términos a la potencia
y posteriormente hacia el producto,
así es que esto es igual a
125 elevada a la potencia 1/3  por...
por" x" a la sexta, elevado a la potencia 1/3,
por "y" al cubo,
elevado a la potencia 1/3.
Ahora veamos cómo
podemos simplificar cada uno de estos términos.
125...
vamos a ver cómo lo podemos factorizar
en factores primos,
para ver si hay algunos que se repitan 3 veces,
1 ó 2 que se puedan repetir 3 veces...
entre 125, es igual a
5 por 25
y 25 es igual a 5 por 5.
Así es que 125 es igual a 5 por 5, por 5,
ó 5 al cubo...
5 al cubo elevado a la 1/3,
esto nos va a dar exactamente igual a 5.
Se simplifica entonces como 5 por...
y ahora "x" a la sexta
elevada a la 1/3.
Esto ya lo hemos visto en otros videos,
si tenemos algo elevado a un exponente
que a la vez se eleva a otro exponente,
se multiplican los exponentes.
Aquí tenemos "x" a la sexta elevado a la 1/3,
esto es igual a "x" a las 6 por 1/3,
"x" a las 6/3 es igual a "x" cuadrada.
Así es que esto de aquí se simplifica
como "x" cuadrada... "x" cuadrada,
y finalmente
aplicamos aquí el mismo principio,
"y" al cubo elevado a la 1/3 es
"y" a la 3 por 1/3,
"y" elevado a la potencia 3/3 ó "y" a la 1.
Por lo que esto está multiplicado por "y".
Hemos terminado.
Y si no quieres escribir estos signos de multiplicación, esto lo puedes escribir como 5,
5x cuadrada... 5x cuadrada "y".
Y hemos simplificado.